vor anderthalb jahren habe ich mir auf
diesem kanal zum ersten mal die frage
gestellt aber vielleicht ist das ganze
und wie viel geld kann man damit
wirklich verdienen
seitdem habe ich fast alles probiert es
mit dem man online einkommen generieren
kann fiber aktienhandel bezahlte
umfragen online casino live-streaming
app-entwicklung online poker musik auf
spotify nochmal aktienhandel bitkom
mining betreibt online gaming und vor
kurzem krippenkunst all diese methoden
haben vor und nachteile aber fast alle
haben eines gemeinsam man macht etwas
sammelt geld in seinem account und muss
dann mehrere tage warten bis zur
auszahlung aber wer hat schon lust zu
warten was muss man im netz tun um jetzt
sofort geld zu bekommen was ist der
schnellste weg mit dem man sich im netz
bequem von zu hause aus etwas
dazuverdienen kann um sich anschließend
zum beispiel etwas hübsches im internet
verstehen zu koennen bevor wir uns jetzt
also nach einer neuen möglichst
sofortigen methode um suchen werfen wir
mal einen genaueren blick auf meine
bisherigen versuche und zu sortieren sie
nach geschwindigkeit wir fangen an mit
dem langsamsten platz zehn teilen sich
spotify und tritt im juni waren es von
spotify 615 dollar 696 euro und 81 cent
riecht fürchtet nicht nur muss man bei
beiden mindestens 30 tage waren bis zur
auszahlung hauptsächlich aber muss man
sich für beides extrem langwierig
reichweite aufbauen da kann es monate
oder auch jahre dauern und genug
follower zusammen zu haben um auch nur
den ersten euro zu sehen platz neun ist
es eine eigene app zu entwickeln 204
euro das heißt durch in der käufe kommt
tatsächlich viel mehr um als mit der
werbung hier kann man zwar auch ohne
reichweite erfolg haben zum beispiel
wenn man sie sich einfach in form von
werbung zum beispiel für 50 euro
allerdings braucht man dafür eben halt
auch eine app die extrem gut überzeugt
sind nutzer sehr sehr schnell guckt und
dann ihn auch lange einer stange hält
bei der stange hält an der stange hält
ich glaube das heißt bei der stange hält
und dazu kommt noch dass die ganzen
auszahlungen auch über ein monat dauern
platz acht ist eine fts verkaufen also
krük und noah ich hatte einfach einer
300 dollar geboten denn auch hierfür
braucht der künstler eigentlich zuerst
fans die sich für seine kunst
interessieren es ist aber zumindest
theoretisch möglich mit strategie und
ein bisschen glück innerhalb von einer
halben stunde ein nfc zu erstellen und
einen käufer zu finden und
das geld in form von crypto währungen
direkt auf sein konto bzw 11 zu erhalten
in der praxis aber muss man dafür auch
erstmal reichweite aufbauen und das
dauert lange
wenn man aber reichweite hat kann man
mit crypto kunst aber wirklich recht
schnell viel geld verdienen diese
animierte pixel delfin mit einem
startgebot von 3 dollar wurde
versteigert für unfassbare 1500 bevor
wir also zu platz sieben kommen der
ersten methode die jeder ohne reichweite
einfach so machen kann beantworten wir
eine spannende frage die ich sehr häufig
gestellt werde und zwar ob ich gewinne
aus diesen experimenten auch versteuern
muss und ja mit meinem persönlichen
steuersatz kann ich also nicht mal 60
prozent davon gehalten und das obwohl
mein steuerberater das in der
steuererklärung bis ins letzte detail
optimieren um das beste für mich
rauszuholen aber auch die 90 prozent der
bevölkerung die nicht selbständig sind
also die angestellten hat sowieso und
studenten unter euch und mit einer
steuererklärung von tex fix unserem
heutigen sponsor in wenigen minuten im
schnitt 1000 27 euro pro jahr zurück
holen und das ist so verdammt einfach da
fange ich als selbständiger fast das
weinen erst bist du bist ein paar
einfache fragen zum beispiel ob du
verheiratet bist oder kinder hast steuer
wirst du brauchst nicht ganz kannst du
direkt eine lohnsteuerbescheinigung ein
dass der titel den wir immer von einem
chef krieg ist alles andere wird dann
automatisch ausgewertet und du siehst
kostenlos wie viele zurück bekommen
kannst du zahlst erst dann wenn du mehr
als 50 euro vom finanzamt zurück kriegst
und kann dadurch unterm strich nur
gewinnen text fix macht das zu 100%
digital über die offizielle elster
schnittstelle und ihr habt zu keinem
zeitpunkt kontakt zum finanzamt und
glaubt mir niemand will kontakt zum
finanzamt haben wenn ich jetzt gerne
über den link in der beschreibung heraus
wie viel er vom finanzamt zurückbekommen
könnt und spart danach 15 mit dem coach
tommy kommen wird zudem geld für die
methoden mit denen jeder auch ohne
reichweite was dazuverdienen kann platz
sieben bezahlt das gaming es war
permanent einfach ein christi fit um
diese ganze branche ist ich mache alles
um herauszufinden ob ich hier
draufklicken kann und wie die fünf euro
versichern kann ja das gibt's wirklich
mobile game also app-entwickler bezahlen
so genannte geld apps mit denen man eben
geld verdienen kann dafür dass diese
neue spiele gewinnen man selbst spielt
also dann das spiel von dem entwickler
der bezahlt dann quasi die geld und die
lässt ein bisschen daran teilhaben und
man verdient auch was und der
spieleentwickler auf dann dass man
süchtig werden was ein ganzes geld für
sein spiel aus gips aber das machen wir
stecken das selber an in meinem
experiment hatte ich so innerhalb von 48
stunden
fünf euro verdient wieder nach drei
tagen auch auf paypal aus sagt jeder
paypal oder die dann nach drei tagen auf
paypal ausgezahlt wurden der stundenlohn
ist miserabel aber so hat immerhin jeder
nach fünf bis sieben tagen ungefähr fünf
euro die er dann in seinen lieblings
peter ring game investieren oder führen
usb stick auf den kopf hauen kann
platz sechs bezahlt der umfragen ist ein
ähnliches system und findet ebenfalls
nach wunsch ausschließlich am smartphone
statt ich bin echt überrascht das ist
jetzt in einer woche 30 euro dabei
rumgekommen diese umfragen werden von
unternehmen in auftrag geben die
natürlich einfach gerne marktforschung
betreiben und leben wissen wollen wer
welche produkte gerne kaufen möchte zum
beispiel deswegen zahlen unternehmen
dafür geld zwar immer noch nicht extrem
viel und die dauer bis die auszahlung
stattfindet ist ähnlich lang wie beim
bezahlten gaming aber der
durchschnittliche stundenlohn ist
deutlich höher und zwar beim einem
experiment bei drei euro damit konnte
ich in einer woche jeden abend so ein
bis zwei stunden mal ein paar umfragen
machen 30 euro verdient die dann auch
nach wenigen tagen überwiesen wurden
bezahlte umfragen je nach anbieter ist
also hier das erste was ich aus dieser
liste wirklich empfehlen würde welcher
anbieter das genau war und auch die
ganzen anderen infos zu diesen ganzen
methoden findet ihr übrigens in den
jeweils ganzen videos dazu in der video
beschreibung platz fünf fall war
jeder kennt videos wie dieses hier wie
wäre es denn wenn mir jetzt einfach für
wenig geld für mittel geld und für viel
geld einfach den us kinos in 3d
modellieren lassen würden aber auf der
freelancer plattform kann man nicht nur
andere leute dafür beauftragen arbeit zu
machen sondern auch selber welche
erledigen und dabei geld verdienen 828
882 euro verdient in meinem ersten monat
kam so also bei einer ungefähren 25
stunden woche fast 900 euro zustande und
das wäre bei steigenden beruf und
steigenden bewertungen natürlich noch
gestiegen zum thema geschwindigkeit ich
hatte deutsch nach zwei tagen meinen
ersten kunden und hätte mir das geld
dann auch innerhalb von ein bis drei
werktagen beweisen können es ist also
etwas schneller und deutlich
ertragreicher als online umfragen nur
mit dem einzigen nachteil hat hat man
dafür halt irgendwas können muss machst
du nix platz vier bitcoin bzw drückt um
einen 1 euro 92 am tag
das ist natürlich jetzt nur für diesen
einen pc wie das unter der haube genau
funktioniert ist super komplex aber ich
um damit geld verdient muss dafür nichts
weiter tun als programm auf meinem pc
installieren und den dann 24 stunden am
tag laufen lassen in diesem zeitraum hat
mein pc mit einer recht guten
grafikkarten atx 20 80 umgerechnet
träger drei euro 60 gesammelt abzüglich
91 so um kosten also 170 profite pro tag
und hier ist das beste dass das geld
wirklich einen tag nach dem 24 stunden
zeitraum schon bei mir war in meinem
fall weil ich direkt drei pcs
gleichzeitig laufen lassen habe waren es
ungefähr zehn euro dann ein nachteil ist
dabei aber natürlich der schwankende
bitcoin preis der war im februar nämlich
bei 38.000 zwischenzeitlich war er bei
52.000 und aktuell leider nur bei 30.000
dadurch lohnt sich das ganze natürlich
mal mehr mal weniger und mal gar nicht
wenn man halt auch noch strom zahlen
muss weitere kritikpunkte sind der
grafikkarten verschleiß und natürlich
die enormen kosten für unsere umwelt
abgesehen davon ist es aber mit ein bis
zwei tagen bis zur auszahlung die bisher
schnellste variante geld zu verdienen
wir haben die top 3 erreicht es wird
also spannend denn die letzten drei
plätze haben alle etwas mit glück zu tun
und so muss ich am platz 3 online casino
setzen obwohl ich das niemals empfehlen
würde niemanden das waren jetzt 100 euro
in weniger als einer stunde einfach
heraus geblasen wie ist dann der verlauf
jetzt mit den spielsüchtigen weißes
wunder zahl wie viele ungefähr
na dann verzockt hass und geld zu
verdienen macht online casino natürlich
null sind statistisch gesehen ist
glücksspiel immer so ausgelegt dass der
betreiber auf lange frist immer gewinnt
jeder der denkt er könnte diese systeme
austricksen ist entweder spielsüchtig
oder schlecht in mathe oder beides da
ist in diesem ranking aber hauptsächlich
um die geschwindigkeit geht muss ich
leider am platz drei setzen obwohl ich
natürlich in einem experiment 500 euro
direkt einfach komplett verloren hat
weil theoretisch wenn ich gewinne
gemacht hätte hätte ich sofort auszahlen
können ähnlich schnell geht die
auszahlung bei unseren platz zwei online
poker
[Musik]
weder das ich bin hier
aha jetzt die ohne 20 dollar im plus
auch hier kann man leicht süchtig werden
und eine menge geld verlieren poker ist
aber deutlich komplizierter als im
online casino einfach gegen welche
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnungen zu stupsen
da man hier nicht gegen knallhart in
mathematik 1 kämpft sondern gegen andere
menschen mit ihr und emotionen ist das
bin ich nicht eins zu eins vergleichbar
mit glücksspiel und selbst wenn hier
alles nur auf glück basieren würde wäre
die chance im 1 1 duell zu gewinnen ja
dann 50 prozent und zu verlieren auf 50
prozent ist wer sich also auch die dauer
ausgleichen
trotzdem machen fast 90 prozent aller
online pokerspieler verlust und haben
jetzt die teilweise sehr sehr dicken
gewinne der top 10 prozent zu
ermöglichen und wenn ihr auch nur einen
hauch zu spielsucht nike könnte hier
auch deutlich mehr als geld verlieren
also lasst es platz eins aus den sachen
die ich in meinen videos bereits
probiert habe ist in sachen
geschwindigkeit cfd trading und das kann
ich jetzt auch nicht wirklich
entschuldigen weil das nämlich wirklich
dumm und das sieht dann im ganzen grafik
so aus
die die es nicht kennen das ist jetzt
mal ganz grob gesagt wie aktienhandel
nur auf steroiden also alle gewinne
werden zum beispiel vor hundertfach
verluste ach man natürlich auch
theoretisch kann man hier in wenigen
minuten sein geld verdoppeln und sich
den gewinn dann direkt danach auszahlen
zwischen 70 und 80 prozent aller nutzer
machen aber auch hier verlust ich
persönlich würde cfd-trading tatsächlich
deutlich riskanter und unberechenbarer
als online poker einstufen und für 90
prozent aller menschen ist das auch
einfach nur gesellschaftlich anerkanntes
glücksspiel und mindestens genauso
gefährlich allerdings kommen wir zu dem
punkt ist dass hier ein ranking in dem
es um zeit geht und häufig ist ja das
ganze trading zeug bereits mit einer
bank verbunden wenn man seine position
schließt also sein handeln beendet
dauert nur minuten oder sekunden bis das
geld dann bei einem da ist also
zumindest wenn man glück hatte und
profit gemacht hat an sich würde hier
also vielmehr eher langfristiges und
diversifiziertes investieren ohne
hebelprodukte empfehlen aber dafür sind
wir ja nicht hier wir wollen ja schnell
geld und das ohne risiko paket das na ja
da gibt es ein fundamentales problem
warum auch immer geben menschen nicht
einfach so fremden leuten geld die
wollen dann erst mal dass man sich
verifiziert damit sie die auf vertrauen
können und es dauert schon ein paar tage
und dann muss man für das geld doch
meistens noch irgendwas machen wenn wir
herausfinden wollen was die schnellste
art ist geld zu verdienen müssen wir aus
meinem erfahrungsbereich rausgehen ich
habe dafür wirklich sehr lange
recherchiert und es gibt eigentlich nur
drei dinge band sammeln irgendetwas
verkaufen was man eh schon hartz iv und
jemanden ausrauben aber das ist ja keine
lösung für mich hoffentlich für
pfandflaschen sammeln braucht man aber
natürlich keine verifikation die
auszahlung ist nahezu sofort und der
stundenlohn ist je nach standort
deutlich lukrativer als zum beispiel
online umfragen aber das spricht
natürlich nicht für flaschen sammeln
sondern eher gegen online-umfragen das
einzige was davon aber für die meisten
von euch wahrscheinlich in frage
kommende ist da ist über plattformen wie
zb ebay kleinanzeigen oder kleider
kreise sachen zu verkaufen die ja eh
schon habt und nicht braucht ich würde
sagen dass es tatsächlich mit abstand
der beste weg ist jetzt sofort geld zu
verdienen im idealfall geht das je nach
standort je nach wohnort relativ schnell
einen käufer zu finden der dann vorbei
kommen sich deswegen abholt und entweder
das geld etwa gibt oder eben per paypal
beim erstellen von diesem ranking ist
eine relativ gute lektion aufgefallen
und zwar die dringender ihr jetzt in
diesem moment geld braucht desto
schlechter sind die optionen die er
dafür haben online-umfragen
glücksspielen leichtsinniges cfd trading
oder sogar jemanden auszurauben sind
jetzt
nicht wirklich tolle option geld zu
verdienen der grund warum menschen die
an drogensucht erkrankt sind häufig zur
kriminalität gezwungen werden ist ja
folgender sie haben oft leider keine
andere wahl als jetzt sofort an dieser
stelle ihre nächste dosis zu
organisieren und brauchen dafür jetzt
sofort geld die lektion hier wäre also
wenn ihr auf sofortigen konsum
verzichten könnt geduld habt und langer
zeit arbeit in etwas investieren könnt
wie zum beispiel eine ausbildung ein
studium selbständigkeit oder unternehmen
hatte eben viel lukrativere und schönere
optionen hoffen jemand der jetzt sofort
geld braucht oder sogar jetzt sofort
reich werden will der muss in aller
regel auf diese nicht so ganz
empfehlenswerten option zurückgreifen
diebstahl geld mit quick scan sam adams
betrügerische onlinekurse uneben eine
ganze menge andere sachen die euch junge
männer im geliebten sport wegen andrehen
wollen
ich hoffe also dass das hier das letzte
video war dass du dir zum thema
schnelles geld verdienen anschauen will
ist man sollte sich damit lieber die
zeit lassen wenn man die wahl hatte die
aber keine zeit lassen solltest ist es
über den link in der beschreibung dem it
takes fix durchschnittlich 1000 27 euro
vom finanzamt zurückzuholen und danach
diesen kanal zu abonnieren
denn dann sehen wir zunächst mal auch
wieder ich würde sagen ich bin doch ein
schönes wochenende
macht's gut
[Musik]